c'est étonnant non
mais qu'est-ce que tu fais ma chérie
tu vois Amandine Josette ma chérie je
lave le costume de scène de pierre mais
il fallait beaucoup je pense bien
Amandine Josette ma chérie il se roule
par terre tous les soirs à 20h30 au
Théâtre grève indice boulevard
Montmartre métro rue Montmartre
richelieu-drôme relâche dimanche et
lundi et là le monde Josette ma chérie
je n'arriverai jamais au bout de ses
tâches ne pleure pas Marguerite Sophie
ma chérie pour ton linge fais comme moi
j'ai un truc super
j'utilise de la lessive de la lessive
Amandine Josette chérie avait raison
depuis que j'ajoute de la lessive à mon
eau de lavage mon linge est moins salé
la vache qu'avant
merci la lessive
alors pierre il y a aucun problème là il
faut que vous fassiez de la pub
maintenant
d'annoncer que c'était de la pub et la
meilleure façon de l'annoncer c'était de
me lancer comme produit en parlions une
pub alors on va on va lire un extrait de
votre petite plaquette pour annoncer
votre prochain spectacle et puis vous
allez la commenter ce nouveau spectacle
d'une facture un peu moins sophistiquée
que le premier afin d'être plus
compréhensible à l'entendement des plus
con ce composera d'une série de vrais
sketchs avec des vrais morceaux de
bravoure entier dedans relié entre eux
par une bassesse d'inspiration qui
volera au-dessus de la ceinture du
moindre nain ça c'est méchant malgré
quelques bouffées de tendresse qui
pourraient se compter sur les doigts de
la main du baron en pin c'est pas gentil
[Musique]
mais si mais au contraire c'est parce
que je pensais à lui si vous aimez quand
on tourne les choses en dérision
[Musique]
le métro c'est pas drôle c'est même mais
c'est quand même pour employer un mot
terrible un peu plus moral
vous allez encore parler de votre
coiffeur que vous n'aimez pas et de la
maladie dont vous avez un petit peu il
me poursuit avec des ciseaux donc pour
mes masculin donc je veux pas plus de
nouvelles non j'ai trouvé d'autres
victimes je m'en prends un sac à Rohff
notamment oui parce que oui saga c'est
pas seulement un doute peut être écorché
que broie la main de fer d'un état de
talitaire c'est quand même la crapule
qui a inventé la deuxième moitié du
programme d'anéantissement total de la
planète sa car il faut pas l'oublier
alors j'ai un sketch qui s'appelle
garder sa caroffe et j'ai tout prévu
s'il le libère dans huit jours mon
sketch s'appellerave goum
vous allez vous adapter à l'actualité
comme le fait Bedos par exemple dans
cette
c'est mon copain oui non pas trop pas
trop non ce que je vais faire par
rapport si vous voulez mon premier
spectacle c'est que ce sont plus des
sketchs que des monologues un peu un peu
de nouvelles victimes en dehors de sa
carotte les Juifs oui j'ai eu beaucoup
d'amis juifs qui m'énervent voilà je
fais un truc antisémite original en ce
moment c'est amusant ça peut plaire
qu'est-ce que j'ai d'autres comme
victime
les enfants
oui les enfants qui à propos de la fête
des mères qui commencent à nous les
gonfler avec leurs petits cadeaux
merdique alors je me suis fait les
enfants vous allez vous faire une
quantité d'ennemis avec les enfants
alors on va regarder un deuxième un
deuxième flash publicitaire un deuxième
écran comme disent les radios privés
les tests n'ont prouvé dans une soirée
mondaine traditionnelle les rigolo
ordinaires s'essouffent et cessent
d'être rigolo au bout de quelques
minutes alors que Pierre Desproges
continuent d'être rigolo pendant des
heures et des heures
Pierre Desproges le rigolo qui dure
vraiment plus longtemps
[Musique]
alors Bernard Tapie devrait pas d'humour
voisins d'en face vous avez été en face
de lui enfin discussion avec lui oui
je lui dis qu'il était beau c'est vrai
il est très joli
il a été sidéré un peu j'aime pas les
footballeurs ni tout ce qui tourne
autour de apparemment ça s'est très bien
passé avec Monsieur Ambroise roux vous
avez vu
tout à l'heure qu'il avait du génie il a
cru que je me payer sa tête
est-ce que vous avez été dérangé à un
moment quelconque parce qu'il a dit là
depuis tout à l'heure
chaque fois qu'il y a une émission de
vie je la suis tout même un peu
anarchiste sur les bords et de dire que
c'est un plaisir de l'entendre
est-ce que ça vous gêne pierre si on
vous dit qu'il y a une petite part de
Coluche chez vous dans cette manière de
tourner les choses en direction
d'attaquer tout le monde que la petite
part de Coluche c'est pas le casque et
la moto vous pouvez y aller au contraire
je voudrais toucher
bien merci Pierre alors il faut quand
même dire que vous avez passé au théâtre
Grévin c'est ça oui parce que le 1er
octobre à partir du 1er août ça va être
très bien et vous êtes venu en tête de
midi parce que vous allez faire une
tournée
ce qu'on appelle on appelle ça d'un mot
d'un mot affreux dans le métier du
spectacle je vais roder mon spectacle
moi je vais pas gentil pour ceux qui
vous regardent en Suisse exactement moi
je vais pas roder c'est à dire qu'il est
prêt je changerai pas un mot mais je
veux voir si les Suisses comprennent
simplement
merci beaucoup
[Musique]